all right best not quarterbacks in
the afc south that's today's
draft chris we've done it with the nfc
west we've done it with the afc north
and the nfc north here's the trivia
question for you
julio jones is 20th all time
with 12 896
career receiving yards what
tight end is ahead of julio jones
as number 19 on the all-time receiving
yardage list i knew this one because i
was looking it up last week when i was
checking out julio jones numbers do you
know tight end
ahead of julio jones and his 12 896
yards
oh okay so let me talk this out i mean
the tight end's not currently playing
right now this is somebody that's
retired right
tony gonzalez has more than that wait so
this there is somebody playing right now
is what you're telling me
no i didn't say anything it's anything
it's a guy that you have to stop and
think is he playing right now
is he you have to stop and think is he
playing right now damn you're killing me
here
um well gronk is playing
all right i'm i'm going to say shannon
sharp i'm wrong though
but that's not a guy yes who is it jason
whitton
oh i would have not come to that i did
not get that
through my brain there at any point so
it's that yeah good clue though that was
a good clue thanks
i i the only reason i would have known
it is last week when we were talking
about julio jones i pulled up the
all-time list and i'm scrolling up and i
remember seeing joe jason witten's got
more receiving yards than julio jones so
uh yeah just kind of an underrated take
for granted
guy who was just kind of there but has
had
an incredible career and could be
destined for canton by the time it's all
said and done
all right best non-quarterbacks
in the afc south
if derek henry is the best running back
in the nfl how can he
not be the best non-quarterback in his
division i'm scanning over the names
just to be safe i will say derek henry
final answer best non-quarterback in the
afc
south yeah i i don't i'm not i don't
think you can argue that
i'm with you there that's that's a good
pick i mean damn he's too good
that's that's the first pick the problem
really is the second pick
that's where it's like there's a lot of
teams or players here
that are in the conversation for best
you know
not all right i'm gonna go with quentin
nelson
i don't give a damn i'm going with it
yeah i am
he's he's one of the best offensive
linemen in all of football
he's the best guard in all the football
i mean they're talking they talked about
man we might move him out to tackle
i'm gonna go with him he's a force of
nature he's a phenomenal football player
i'll go with quentin nelson
yeah hey look you know it's easy to
overlook an offensive lineman
uh when they do their job well we don't
notice them
we notice everyone else but quentin
nelson is one of those guys
one of those rare offensive linemen when
he does his job well you still notice
him because he's putting guys on there
yeah that's right
so i i i can't disagree with you on that
one
all right it does get very challenging
after this there's a lot of great
players
uh a lot a lot of really good that's
what it is great players
right in the afc south all due respect
i'll go to force buckner i thought that
would be your first yeah that was the
white force of nature
pick from the trade excuse me from the
49ers he was great last year made that
defense better
and and really colts titans man watch
out for as bad
as the texans are and the jaguars
possibly will be
colts and titans are going to be at the
top of that division and and uh
it's going to be some battles this year
between those two teams yeah it
definitely is i mean
yeah that's who i was i was split
between so i went with the big ugly on
the offensive side of the ball but
buckner certainly is in the running for
that i mean he's
a force of nature defensive tackle
defense
and you know the stats don't really tell
the truth of how good he is and we saw a
little last year right
he missed a game or two there and their
defense wasn't quite the same
so that that's where where it's special
all right
here we go i'm gonna go with julio here
i'm gonna make julio the next pick
yeah i'm going julio jones here uh you
know even though i know statistically
is it's not as good as like you know aj
brown and everything like that i still
think julio's
a hair more special at this point of his
career than aj brown who's a phenomenal
receiver
and i really love uh but julio with that
size
he still has game breaking speed of
course the experience there's really
just not a weakness to his game as we've
discussed
other than is the health thing all where
we want it to be
and that's that that doesn't seem to be
an issue for the titans so i'm going to
go julio jones with my next one
yeah you know he was destined to make it
it just is it's
it's challenging to figure out exactly
where to drop him
right um wow oh boy
i'd go bud dupreeh here now but we don't
know about his health
i know you know um i i i'll go with uh
i'll go with laramie tunzel let's give
the texans a little love
okay uh i think that's the right pick
yeah i
was the highest paid tackle in football
until he got jumped by david bakutiari
who got jumped just a little bit by
trent williams a guy that they gave up a
lot to get
and a guy who has to be looking around
the locker room wondering where the hell
did everybody go
uh in in houston but uh a rare bright
spot in a team that's got a long way to
go to be a contender yeah i i mean he is
he's a rare bright spot i mean
as i sat here and looked at this i was
like man is he going to be the only
texan guy that gets drafted here really
you know we'll see
but i think at the very least you know
whatever you want to talk about his
trade or what he's getting paid either
way
laramie tunzel is hands down one of the
best pass protecting offense alignment
in football
if not the best you could put him in
that if i had a offensive coach go
oh i think laramie tunze is the best pa
i wouldn't go oh you're crazy that's
stupid i can't believe you think that
he's worthy of of that type of praise so
i'm with you there
i don't think that's that bad all right
i'll go darius leonard next i'm gonna go
darius leonard middle linebacker
even though like last year i didn't i
think was like he killed it killed it
his best year
as compared to you know the year before
and the expectations he
set that way uh he's still you know an
unbelievable player and your modern day
nfl linebacker i mean phenomenal in
coverage can fly around the field
sideline to the sideline
he's really a much needed piece for that
defensive system
which makes it go so that's why he's so
important and he's a damn good football
player
we we have a list of possible options
that pete has compiled and
he's a smart ass because there's a six
string tight end
from jacksonville that he's put at the
very bottom
i see what you're up to pete pete's
trying to stir it up a little bit i'll
go aj brown here yeah
i mean if julio jones is on it aj
brown's not far behind him
and uh we're gonna see how good aj brown
is with
julio jones there to take some of the
heat away from a guy who
who had had seen up johnny smith leave
in free agency adam humphreys leaving
free agency corey davis leaving free
agency it was going to be the aj brown
one-man band catching passes now all of
a sudden
it's aj it's julio it makes it easier
for aj brown in year three
and remember there was a little rookie
year yeah it was close between aj brown
and dk metcalf
dk separated some last year but aj's
still there
yeah i think i think we could be we
could be talking about aj
brown as every bit as good if not better
than dk metcalf after this season
it's really close it was really close
even just talking about aj brown and
julio jones right now
you know i mean again i think if you
took aj brown before julio jones i would
have been like oh wow that's just
egregious how dare
you disrespect yeah i mean the guy the
guy
i mean i don't know i just feel like
every sunday you turn on a game aj
brown's going for a 50-yard touchdown
pass
something like that i mean it's not like
bull
bull crap you know oh we got him a bunch
of easy screen passes and throw like
throws like that
to pat his stats i mean look at this
it's 20.2
per reception year one 15.4 last year
i mean it's that's phenomenal it's as
big a play receiver as you're gonna find
in football so
i don't know as we sit here and talk i
go maybe i should have took him over
julio maybe it's closer than i'm
or maybe he is better in the prime of
his career that way um
jeffrey simmons will be my next one
tennessee titans jeffrey simmons
i think after deforest buckner is
the best defensive lineman in the
division right now
simmons is a a beast in the middle got
like
the power of a guy that's 330 pounds
but he's 305 pounds and has really good
quickness too
so he's got like scheme versatility for
the tennessee titans that's important
because sometimes they ask their guys to
like two gap hold the guy up and just
disengage
other times they just go go through
there like a you know
a bat out of hell and fly through that
gap and he can kind of do both he's a
really damn good player to me
yeah look that's a good pick i thought
about him earlier as well we're looking
at round five now no jaguars yet and i
will not be picking their six string
tight end but i will be
picking linebacker miles yeah the only
guy left from that defense
that was so dominant in 2017 they were
on the cusp of the super bowl
and and miles jack is amazing me because
remember he fell into round two when he
came out in the draft because his knee
was messed up and
he he's still finding a way to play at a
high level
with a knee that is far from 100 and
just think about how great he would be
if he had both knees and 100 so a lot of
credit for miles jack
and hopefully that team will become a
contender while he's still there i don't
want him to become the paul puzzle
of this iteration of the jaguars who
just as soon as he's gone they all of a
sudden figure it out
i hope they figure it out while miles
jack's still on the team yeah no i well
i mean we got to see how special he was
like as a second year
player you know hey i mean you talk
about it all the time they don't blow
that whistle did down in new england
he's running up the sidelines and see
you later jacksonville and blake bortles
are going to the super bowl that's
because like like i'm glad you picked
him
you know miles jack is he's one of the
best defensive players in football
and he can be my middle linebacker any
day i got a man crush on him i love
watching him play and you're right i
mean he's battled some of the knee
history and things like that but
man he's explosive as hell and yeah he's
kind of stuck in a tough situation there
all right they'd have been up 17 points
yes 13 minutes left
championship yeah i know that's i mean
i'm not going to put anything back
behind you know past brady and belichick
but that would have been
tough um man you know we still have
taylor lewand and bud dupree on the
board
and they're both worthy of being taught
like i think our their injuries have
affected us here
or they would have been picked already
i'm gonna go with bud dupree right
right here yeah i don't know if he'll be
100 to start the season he probably
won't be
but you know week eight or ten he will
be and
he is like without question one of the
best edge defenders in the game
he's a great pass rusher but he's more
than just a pass rusher too
i mean he is a real like run stopper
force of nature that way i love bud
dupree
and i mean i think we saw him last year
he was kind of just reaching his
potential when he finally
when he hurt that knee but that was a
much needed acquisition by the tennessee
titans
yeah and it's easy to forget about that
because
we don't know what's going to happen
with the knee but they're comfortable
with it
obviously they gave him a real contract
too with guarantees into the second year
they're going all in because they know
if he is healthy they're going to have
one hell of a pass rush is going to make
that defense even better
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports